で 大体一体全体仏教って何でしょうかと
もし聞かれたら 我々はどういうふうに答えますかと
大体これは日本ではそんなに問題ないんだけど
皆様仏教って何であろうかと分かっていらっしゃるかもしれませんだけど
たまに我々は冗談で自分の国の人々に聞くんですね
みんな仏教徒だと思っているし
いろいろ修行もするし
一生懸命真剣に頑張ってはいるんだけど
たまに聞くんです あなた方は仏教って何ですかと
知ってますかと で その時
やっぱりこれは日本の方々にとってはそんな問題はないかもしれませんだけど
やっぱりそういうテーラワーダの世界の方々も
そういう質問されたら
何となく驚いちゃうんですね
どう答えればいいかとわからなくなっちゃうんですね
一体仏教って何ですかと
で それに簡単なことは
答えは この物事のありさま
ありとあらゆる因縁によるものですよと
いろんな原因があって
いろんな条件があって
他のものは生まれていきますよという法則を教えているというのは
仏教の教えなんです で
それはもう簡単な答えなんですね
いわゆるお釈迦様は因縁の話を教えているんだと
縁起論を 論とは言えませんだけど
話しているんだと 仏教は縁起説だよと言ったっても構いません
で 縁起の教えっていうのは
まあこの ごく普通に言ってる縁起ではないんです
縁起のいいとか縁起の悪いとかね
そういう意味ではなくて
で 縁起の教えっていうのはなぜ？という質問に答えなんですね
なぜという で どんなものにもなぜという言葉は出せますからね
なぜ私は立ってるんですかと
なぜ皆様方お座りになってるんですかと
なぜ私はこのホールの中にいるんですかとか
どんなものにもなぜということはつけられますね
そのなぜというのはつけられますから
そこに何か答えもあるはずなんですね
で 大体簡単に言えばそんなもんなんですね
縁起論というのは ただ
何かあったら それに知りたければなぜというこのはてなを入れてみる
それでそのわけが現れてきます
ということは わけがなく何も現れるわけはないんです
何かあるならば それにはそれなりの
理由があるんです ものすごい当たり前のことなんです
そんなこと話す必要もないほどの当たり前のことなの
わけがあってあるんだと
で なんでこんな当たり前のことはそんなに難しい話だと普通私たちは思っているんでしょうかね
特に我々はそう思っているんですね
あの 私たちはやっぱり縁起の話は難しいんだと
みんな難しいと思っているわけじゃないんです
そんなものはまあ いとも簡単だと思っている方々もね
そういう理解できる人々はいるかもしれませんし
で まあ一応仏教の伝統では難しい話だとは言ってるんです
この前にも説明したように
この 何でしたっけ お釈迦様の教えを全部勉強なさっていたアナンダ尊者がね
お釈迦様は難しいと言うんだけど
縁起の話っていうのは私にとってはそんなに難しくはないんだと
で お釈迦様に言われたところでお釈迦様はすごくそれ
まあアナンダ尊者を叱るというか
注意させるんですね そんなことは言ってはいけませんと
決して縁起の教えっていうのは簡単単純なものではないんだと
それはとても深く深くて理解しがたいものであると
それは理解するならば
生命というのはいとも簡単に解脱して
幸福を味わうはずですよと
世の中 生命は輪廻の中
延々と生まれて死んでなくなって生まれなくなって
限りない苦しみを味わっているのは
因果のシステムがわからないんだからですよというふうに言われたんですね
ですから まあ難しいと思っても構いません
で じゃあ訳があってものがあるんだということは
なんで我々には役に立つんですかね
それ間違って受け取ると
まあどうでもいいことになっちゃうんですね
例えば何かあったら それなりに訳があるんじゃないんですかと
例えば自分が体の調子が悪かったと
まあ何か訳があって体が調子悪くなったんじゃないですかと
別に気にする必要ないんだと
そういうふうに何だかんだにも言えることは言えるんですよ
例えば兄弟がいて 一人の兄弟は一人がすごい健康的で幸福で
一人はあまり健康がなくて不幸で
それぞれ何か訳があるでしょうね
当然訳があって 一人が健康
不健康で まあ不幸 不幸で
一人が大変健康的で幸福でって
これある訳があってそうなるんですよと
で まあそれぐらいだったら何の役にも立ちませんね
結局 それぐらいだっても訳があってそうなってるんだと
それ知恵でもなんでもないんですね
結局 簡単ですけど 誰にでも言えるんだから
訳があるんですかと 何か訳があるんですと
で 問題はその訳は何ですかと探す時なんですね
なんで私の髪の毛が白くなってるんですかと
で それで何か訳があるんだと
それはありますけど 問題はその訳は何ですかと
それ探す時はもう大変骨が折れる仕事になるんです
で まあそこら辺なんですね
難しいということは 問題は我々にはどうももうこの正しい物事のこの原因ですか
訳っていうのはなかなか見つからないようなことなんですね
で 世の中を見ると 例えば哲学はたくさんある
宗教もたくさんある 人間の考え方もたくさんある
何かについて何か喋ろうと思ったら
いろんな人がいろんな意見を言っちゃう
そういう現象があるんですね
例えば なんでもう今の時期
この2日前 ものすごく寒くなっちゃったんで
いきなり で なんで天気はちゃんと軌道にならないで
いきなり変化するんですかと
異常現象起こりますかと
言ったら いろんな人がいろんなことをそれについて言うんですね
あるいは現在日本の経済は成長しているんですか？あるいはまだまだ前の
要はいい方向に行ってるんですか？まだまだですかと
言えばいろいろ意見が出てくるんですね
それを少々考えてみてください
なんで何かについて私たちはいろんな意見は言ってますかと
それでいろんな意見を言うことは正しいんですか？あるいは間違ってるんですかと
それを理解してほしいんですね
じゃあ私は 私は仏教の立場から言うならば
何か例えば現代社会状況について
なぜ現代社会はこうなってるんですかと
このなぜを聞けば もう100人は100種類の意見は出すんです
みんな同じ意見は言わないんです
こうだからこうなったんですよと
それ大変大事なポイントなんです
それで私はこういうふうに解釈したいんですね
もし何かがあって 例えば現代社会状況
何でもいいんです もうどんなものでも訳があるんだから
で 現代社会状況はなぜこういう風になってるんですかと
言ったら いろんな人がいろんな意見が言って
意見が様々にバラバラになるのは
それはいいと思ってる人もいるし
意見はなかなかまとまらなくて
これ大変だと思う人もいるかもしれませんし
私から言えば 何かの現象が現れたならば
その現象にそれなりの因縁
訳があるはずなんです
それは見つかってないんです
見つかってないんだから
人間がいろんな意見を喋ってるんです
[終始背景音楽]ですから
人間の世界で 社会でいろんなものについていろいろ意見があったり
食い違いがあったり 学説がいっぱいあったりするのは
ひいて言えばどなたでもはっきりした原因は見つかってないということなんです
で見つかったならば これはこれだと
それで終わるんですよ
問題は そういうことで
なんかちょっとおかしい結論出ますけどね
普通我々は現代的な知識を持ってるんだから
人は様々な意見があることは別に何と何とも思わないんですね
私が言うことに人が反対して違う意見を出したっても
よっぽど頭悪い人でない限りはもう何とも思わないんです
自分言ってることこそ正しいんだと
何言ってるんですかとはケンカは売りませんし
そうですかと 相手の意見は聞いて
まあそれごく普通だと思っちゃうんですね
それで同じ仲間であろうか
友達同士であろうか 何かについては全く別々の意見を持ってる可能性はあります
それでも別に何とも思わなく生きているんです
ですから いろいろ意見があるのはごく普通であって
現代的であって それこそ正しいとは一応我々は思ってるんですね
でも よく考えると いろんな意見があるということは
結局どっちが正しいかと
わからないことなんですね
ですから もし正しい意見があるならば
それにはまた違う意見が出るはずがないんですね
ということは このなぜというわけ探していくと
もしわけが見つかったら
そこで全部終わってしまっちゃうんです
それ以上やることは何もなくなっちゃうんです
そういうことで 因縁を知ることは解脱を得ることと同じくなってしまっちゃうんです
まあもっとごく普通なこの本当の因縁の話には入りませんだからもうなかなか難しくて
まああっちこっちグルグル
衛星みたいに回転することしかできませんだけどね
問題は真ん中に置いて回り
で ごく即的な話に戻して考える
例えば健康な体を維持するためには
どういう食べ物を食べた方がいいんですかと
大体みんな興味ある話だから
そこで興味あるだけでは物足りませんし
我々は不思議なことに結構食べてるんですね
生まれた時から ですから
食物に対して何も食べ物に対して何も知りませんとか言ったら
それはおかしいんですし
人間はよく食べてますからね
いつでも何かを食べてるんです
それだったらあなた方は毎日やっていることだから
勉強だったら毎日やってませんし
修行にしたって毎日やってませんし
お寺なんかに来るっていうのは一生一回
二回ぐらいで そんなことだからお寺のことを知りませんと言ったっても
それは分かりますよ 一生一度
二度しか行けませんだから
勉強なんかあんなものは忘れちゃったんですよと言ったってのは分かります
まあまあ分かります それならばもう一日勉強して
それで忘れちゃもうやらないんだから
でも食べることはあれ忘れちゃったっていう人がいませんだから
それだけは忘れませんでちゃんとやってるんですね
それだったら人間っていうのは食べ物に対してはきちんとしたノウハウを持ってるはずなんですね
じゃあいかがでしょうかね
それで私が聞いたら じゃあ体を維持するためにも
体を健康的に保つためには一番ふさわしい食べ物は何ですかと
一番ふさわしい どういう食べ物の方がよろしいですかと聞いたら答えられますかね
正直に 全然答えられませんでしょう
さっぱりわからない 何を食べた方がいいんですか
そこはポイントなんです
原因わかってないんです
大体もう悟りはもうもうゴミ箱に捨ててください
自分の体のこと 健康にいるために
わかってますかね そういうことで
何食べるべきかということさえも理解できないほど難しいんです
だからいっぱい意見があるんですよ
納豆はいいんだと 納豆がいいというと
またある人がやっぱり１種類のたんぱく質取ったらもう大変危険ですよ
また違う意見言っちゃう
じゃあどうしようかと
そうすると じゃあ納豆も食べながら牛肉も食べた方がいいんだと
そこでまた他の人はやっぱり動物
動物性のたんぱく質は体に良くないんだとまた出てきちゃうし
で そういう風にこのあれはいいんだ
これはいいんだ あれは悪いんだ
これは悪いんだとか そういう話ばっかしで
結局はっきりした答えが出てこないんです
例えば体に必要な健康やら若くもう年取るとボケを防止するための必要なこういう食べ物がありますよと言いながら
それはある一種のビタミン
ビタミン Aはどうやって摂れるんですか？ビタミン Eはどうやって摂れるんですかとか
そればっかり食べちゃったらまた栄養失調になっちゃって
また体が壊しちゃうし
そういう話を聞いたのは
やっぱり自分の体を維持するためには
どんな食べ物は どういう食べ方
どういう食べ方がふさわしいかということさえ我々は分かってないんだから
いろんな意見が出てくるということなんです
各国で 国によって意見が違うし
人間の年によって意見が違うし
育ち方によって食べ物に対する意見が違うし
青森で育った人と沖縄で育った人は
体にいい食べ物について食べるなと言ったら全く違うことを言ってるんです
そういうことで 外国の人々もまた違う違うことを言ってるし
まあそういうことで まあ別にもう自分ももう食べることのことさえも知らないんだから
また縁起説なんかはまあ知るわけないんですね
結局簡単に言えば ですから
この縁起というのは大変縁起の悪い話で
なかなか理解しにくいんです
このなぜというものを見つかったら
そこにすべての生命の
すべての宇宙の法則のシステムが見つかるはずなんです
たとえとことん追求して
体と食べ物の関係ちゃんと分かったら
まあ宇宙のシステムが分かったことになるんです
そこまで追っていかなくちゃいけないんです
例えば食べ物 体っていうのはある物体の構造であって
その物体はこの地球から宇宙のものから出来上がってあって
ですから ただ単に宇宙の一部であって
別個 別種的な存在ではないんですね
異物ではないんです 我々は
それなのに それだったらそのままいればいいんだけど
どうも食べ物はあげなくちゃいけないんですね
それで食べ物って何ですかと
自分の存在って何ですか
食べ物でどういう働きしてくれるんですかとか探してみると
やっぱり本質的な物質の働き
いろいろエネルギーの交流
エネルギーの交換 エネルギーの変わり方
いつでも同じ形でいないで
違う違う形に変化しなくちゃいけないといういろんなこと出てくるんです
例えばこのあのフードチェーンですか
この食べ物のこのチェーンみたいに
鎖みたいなね 曲がっているんだから
やっぱり曲がらなくちゃいけないんですね
食べ物のこの鎖っていうもの
で 何て言いますか この海にあのプランクトンですか
小さなプランクトンがあって
それは大きな魚なんか食べたりして
その魚は他のものを食べたりして食べられたりして
それで人間はその魚を食べたりしたりとか
で 回っちゃうんですね
いつでも で 自然の中で
それも一つの法則なんですね
このそのエネルギーはこれで終わりだと
終われることは不可能なんです
やっぱり自分がこの食べ物を食べて
ある時間でそれを使って
それからそれを返さなくちゃいけないんです
自然に 他のエネルギーに
で だから我々には魚でも肉でも食べられるようになっているんです
で 野生的な生活を見るとね
ある動物は死んでしまっちゃう
その動物は生きてる間はいろんなものを食べて食べて生きていて死ぬと
死んじゃったら他の動物が来てそれを食べちゃうと
ですから あのチェーンが
あの鎖というんですか
それはきちんと流れてるんです
で そういうふうな この物質の流れ
またいろいろそういう流れがありまして
それは一つの流れだけなんです
で 人間何食べるべきかといったっても
大体そういう この宇宙の法則の立場から見ると
もっと違うことが分かってきます
そういうふうに考えると
結構ややこしい話にはなるんです
それでもう一つ考えなくちゃいけないのは
何を見ても そういうふうにややこしく
ややこしく わからないほど難しい世界が現れてきます
食べ物だけじゃないんです
どんな現象を見ても もうなぜ雨が降りますか？と考えたってもまあ大変で
例えばもうこの太陽系とかそんなもの出来上がってきて
宇宙が出来上がってきて
どんどんどんどんガスが固まって
そういう風に物質的な
この地球とかね 惑星とか出来上がったんだと思っても
その中でもう同じ時間だから
同じ時間の中でガスがどんどん固まって
地球やらいろんなものが出来上がったならば
同じ物質でなければおかしいんですね
それなのにあるものは鉄であって
あるものは水であって
あるものは酸素であって
あるものは窒素であって
なんであんな落ちこぼれがいるんですかね
この進化の過程で 物質の中で
だから例えば太陽はもともと全部ガスでしたと思うならば
それは固まって固まっていろいろ爆発やいろいろなことが起きて
もうどんどん出来上がったという話もありますし
そうするとみんな一緒に始めたんですね
水も鉄も我々も我々の体で構成している物質も
やっぱりその物質の変化の過程の中でのいろいろ落ちこぼれがいる
いまだに水で止まってるものもあって
土になってるエネルギーもあって
鉄に鉄分になってもう止まってるものもありまして
ある物質はもう DNA アミノ酸になっちゃって
生命生命として変化したりとか
あれえらい複雑なんですね
そういうのを理解することなんですよ
演義説っていうのは で
そういうふうに もうちょっと面白おかしく世の中を見てくると
なんとかわかるはずなんです
だから皆様はとにかく決めてもらわないと
まあすごく私は知識的に責め
責め 責められて責められて
もう私のもう頭はガタガタなんですけど
で かえって私も責めてみたいんです
じゃあそこら辺知りたいんですかと
宇宙の構造やら存在の構造
どういうふうに どういうふうに
どういうふうに出来上がってくるか
とことん徹底的に原因を探しながら
まあちょっと面白おかしく
ちょっと一言言っただけでも
みんなもうもう疲れて疲れて眠くなってあくびばっかり出ると思いますよ
ということはもうわからないということなんです
そういうことで お釈迦様はね
そんなふうにああだこうだとかね
物事を探し回ってもね
物事を探し回っても何になるんですかと
宇宙はどうやって現れたんですかと
あるいは物理学を勉強していたところで
まあ昔々はもうそういう創世故事からあって
まあもう水素ですか 水素があって
それからどんどん変化して
このピーロリーテーブルありますから
その中でどんどん変化して
まあ最終的にはこういうもので全部ありますよとか
そういうふうにはもうあれも全部確実な説明ではないんだけど
なぜならば 僕から見れば物質ではえらい落ちこぼれがいっぱいいるんです
きちんと進化しろと言いたいんだけど
みんな一緒に 一点にじゃなくてもういろんなところで物質が止まってるんだからね
それで問題ですけどまぁ
で そういうことを知ってどうなるんですかと
あるいは知られますかと
そこら辺問題なんです
ですから 要は自分の役に立つところだけ知っておけばいいんじゃないかなということになるし
それについてお釈迦様はやっぱり結局人間っていうのは心の働きですから
心を清らかにする方向だけ考えれば
まあなんとかうまくいくんじゃないかなと
というふうなことで それほど説明ないといえばないんです
で できるだけ今日はゆっくり喋りたいんです
皆様にも考える暇もいくらか与えながら
で この考える暇が当たると
私の頭もすぐボケてしまっちゃうんです
だからそこはもうサッサッと自分の頭の回転と同じ速さでしゃべれないと
で あのもう一回戻して考えましょう
戻して考えるということは
この世の中の我々は原因わからないということ
わからないんだから みんないろんなことを言うし
そこでこれどっちにも当たってない
はっきりと当たってないんだから
この世の中に人間が言っていることについては
我々はそれほど真剣になる必要もないんです
ああ そうですかと聞いて
それだけで十分です あるいは
その人の言い訳をちゃんと言い訳ですか
その三段論法をきちんと理解すればいいのです
例えば宗教の例を出すと
まあ全てはもうパーといきなり神というものに作られたものだとという意見もありまして
それは違いますよと 私たちはわかりませんだからね
わかりません 違いましょうと言えませんし
だからその人になんであなたはこういう
こういうふうに言いますかと
その人の理由を聞いて理解すればいいのです
ただ 信じる必要もないし
否定する必要もないのです
人は私は神様を信じていますよと
そうすると ああそうですか
なぜ信じてるんですかと
なるほど そういうわけですかと
そういうふうに聞いて
それで話は終わりと なぜかというと
ある人は私はこういう
こういうわけで神様を信じていますよと言うと
こういうわけで神様を信じてないんですよと言ってるんです
ということは この二人とも
存在の本当の訳は見つかってないということなんです
ある人はある人々は 人間には徹底的に永遠な魂があるんだと
人は死んでも魂は死にませんと言ってるし
ある人はなんでくだらない話ですかと
人間死んじゃったら自然に戻るんだけど
そういうようなことわかりませんと言ってるし
それどちらでも 結局はっきりしたわけがわかってるわけではなくないということなんですね
違う意見というのは そのその人々もそれぞれ自分に何かわけがあって喋ってるだけなんです
でもそれは完全たる真実ではないんだと
完全たる真実は原因見つかったら
それで全ての探求は終わってしまっちゃうんです
もっと例を出しましょう
例えば私はここに時計があるんです
で 時計は私の手から外れて落ちて壊れたんだと
ちょうど皆様はそれを見ていました
見たところで私は時計を拾って
なぜこの時計は壊れたんですかと聞く
聞いたらどう答えますか？正しいを答えられますか？これ一応実践はしたくないんですけど
まあ安い時計ですけど
で 一応仮定で時計ももうちょっと使えない
で 仮定で考えると 私は皆様に見えるようにこうやってこうやって遊んでいる間は
これドーンと落っちゃって壊れたんだと
私は聞く 時計は壊れています
なぜですかと 答えられますかと
もし答えられると思うならば
私は全然答えられないと言いますし
答えられないと言ったならば答えるというし
どっちを取るんですか
どっち取ったって 私は私の意見出して負けるようにするんです
大抵 だからそういうものなんです
真実っていうのは 例えばそのもっと素朴で言えば
例えば時計は落ちて壊れたんだならば
それについて我々は喧嘩はしません
別に皆様は自分に関係ないんだから喧嘩しないわけではなくて
このなぜ時計が壊れたんですか？という意見については喧嘩しません
それは落っこっちゃったんだから
で 一応決まってるんですね
ですから 原因はっきりと知ってるということは結構いいことなんです
そうするともう喧嘩になりません
だから人間 お互いに分かれて喧嘩や争い
戦争やらいろいろありとあらゆる悩んだりとは苦しみは生まれてこないんです
問題は原因分かってない時なんです
例えば 自分が自分の部屋に家に外から仕事をして終わって家に帰る
帰ったところで 家にあった大事な
もう大変高価な もう何て言いますか
いろいろ思い覚えがある置き時計があります
それはめちゃくちゃ壊れているんだ
そうするとどうですかね
うちにも誰もいないと
そこで問題が生まれるんです
この時計は この時計と違って
あれは壊れているし わからないなぜかと
それでもうありとあらゆる困ること
問題が 悩むこと生まれてくる
で うちの誰かがそれ壊したんですかとまた妄想する
で うちの人々に聞く 聞いたら
もしくは誰か みんな私は知りませんと
私は知りませんと うちのみんな知りませんと言っちゃったら
もう自分がさらに困るんです
あんたがたみんな知りませんだったら
これどうやって壊れたんですかと
もしかすると泥棒入ったんではないか
それだったら大変ではないかと
あるいはそれ泥棒入った形跡見たら全然入ってないんだと
するとそれはさらに怖くなっちゃうんです
うちの人々は誰もこれを壊したわけでもないし
何か物を落っこったわけでもないし
地震が起こったわけでもないし
泥棒入ったわけでもないし
でも時計は壊れてるんだと
怖いでしょ それだったら
もしかするとお化けでも来て
エイリアンでも来てそれ壊した可能性あるんだから
だから原因知らないということは
えらいもう我々にいろんな苦しみを作ってくれるんです
ですから 私はこうやってこの時計を落っこったところで
時計壊れたっても 誰よりももうそれについて全然心配も困ることも悩むこともケンカすることも何もない
原因分かってるんだから
だから そのように我々の生き方について原因見つかってください
そうすると人生はもうそれだけでも結構楽なんです
楽しいんです 苦しみは消えちゃうんです
全部ケンカなくなっちゃう
まあ知ってるんだから
訳はね それにもうちょっとおとなしくならなくちゃいけないことがありますね
訳は知ったからといって
いちいちうるさく もうああだこうだと言う必要はないんです
で そこでもう自分たちがまた新しい
例えば自分もうちの子は頭が悪いんだと
勉強できないんだと決まったところで
それはもうわかってるんです
であるならば 一応落ち着いてるんですね
心は 親の心は まあやっぱり自分
この子はあまり勉強はまあ上手じゃないんだと
それでもそれに我慢しないで
その事実を認めないで
とにかくその労力でも入れて
この勉強できるようにしようと思うと
その人は結局原因が分かってないんですね
自分のわがままで 高慢で
物事を変化させようと
いわゆる宇宙にチャレンジしているんですね
宇宙に 存在にチャレンジしようと
馬鹿野郎と言ってるんですよ
そんなことをするのはもう本人ほど馬鹿がいないんだから
だから冬になってきたら
それは自然の法則でしょうに
皆様方 自分の子供いじめると同じ感じで
馬鹿野郎暖かくなりなさいと言ってみてください
暖かくなってくれるんですかと
あるいは冬を馬鹿にして
冬なんか怖くも何ともないんだと
薄着で外に歩いたり もう仕事をしたりしてみてください
誰が馬鹿を見るんですかと
ですから この因果法則を知るということは
そんな馬鹿なことをしないことなんです
宇宙に攻撃するなと 宇宙法則は宇宙法則だから
我々は何にもないんだから
宇宙のシステムの中で
宇宙の法則の許しがなければ
じゃあ吸えますか？空気を
宇宙の法則に逆らって吸ってみてください
それさえできないんだから
一回の吸うことさえ もう大自然の大宇宙の法則からもうただやらせてもらってるだけなんです
ですから ただ原因わかったということだけではなくて
我々はそういう風に もっと広い心で物事を見られる落ち着きが生まれてくると素晴らしいんです
いじろうとはしない 自然の
自然に対してこんな小さな人間がまあああだこうだとかチャレンジをして
もう勉強嫌いな子は何とかしてもう世界一流の知識人にしたがっちゃうし
で それで人生すごい苦しいしね
別にもう簡単勉強だから何とかすれば何とか合格だけはできますけどね
試験なんか合格するのは勉強したわけにもなりません
それで大学なんか出ちゃうし
それで何か卒業証書あったら取っちゃったら
それ何々専門家になっちゃうんです
でも本人は全くそうじゃないんです
医者になっても医学の勉強嫌いな人は本物の医者じゃないんです
でも彼が一応頭で勉強しているんだから
一生懸命その仕事をするんだけど
本人はそれ苦しいし ひらめきはないし
もう結局苦しくて苦しくて
人生の幸福は台無しになっちゃうんです
ですから 自然法則で何か道が決まっているならば
やっぱりそれに逆らわないで逆らわない方がいいんじゃないかなと思いますけど
で 我々はこのチャレンジするのは宇宙の法則に因果論がわからないだからなんです
宇宙っていうのはもう想像できないんだから
すごい大きいんだから
法則は何もできない 何やってもその法則の中
例えば私はもう法則にチャレンジして新しいものを作りますよと思って作っても
それは宇宙の法則の中で作っているんです
でしょう 例えば 人間はもう全然飛べないんですね
鳥は飛べますけど それで人間がそれで我慢しないで
やっぱりチャレンジしてみようと思って
そういう人々は一生懸命チャレンジして
いろいろ工夫して やっぱり空を飛べるようになったんですね
じゃあ いろんな飛行機が出てきて
今我々は空を飛んであっちこっち行っている
じゃああれは自然に 我々は工芸品で買ったんですか？買ったわけじゃないんです
ただ自然に従っているだけなんです
地球の引力がなければ飛行機は飛びませんだから
我々は飛べないのは地球の引力なんですね
地球に引っ張られているんだから
それに反対の制御はなかなか作れないんですね
だから空は飛べないし
じゃあ飛行機は結局地球から引っ張られてるんだから
飛行機は飛んじゃうんです
飛ぶんです そうでなきゃ飛ばないし
ありとあらゆる法則に従ってるんです
全然逆らったことではないんです
逆らえないんです そういうことで
全ては存在の中でそういう因縁があって
変化してあって そういう原因がわかってくると落ち着きなさいと
落ち着けるんだと  宇宙は巨大であって
宇宙っていうのは 僕はちょっとこのまあまあちょっとちょっと違う意味でとってますけどね
まあその定義は難しいし
で その訳は分かってきたら
別にその世界に対してはね
逆らおうとしない ですから
この訳は知ってから余計にそれを攻撃しようチャレンジしようと壊そうと思わないならば
そこにすごい楽な生き方が出てくる
で 何かいい生き方が出てくるはずなんです
訳が分からないんだから
我々はもうこれについてしゃべるは
あれについてしゃべるは
もうディスカッションからディスカッション
会議 会議 会議 どんな会社でしたっても会議だらけで時間かかっちゃうし
学校でも先生たちはもう会議ばっかしで
で 時間と金がばっかしかかっちゃいますけど
じゃあ何か結論出していい方向行ってるんですか？全然ないんです
僕はもう回ほど何とか国際会議なんかに
このまあそれ仏教の関係とかして
平和平和の国際会議とかももう参加したケースがありまして
若い時は それでも二度とこの有名な国際会議なんかには参加はしませんと
と思って それよりはどこかで誰かと遊んだ方がいいんだと思う
田舎でこの子供たちでもガキたちとこの木を登ったりとか
穴を掘ったりとかね 水遊びしたりとか
そちらの方がもっといいんだなと思ったんです
なぜならば あんな国からこんな国からとか
あんな偉い人 こんな偉い人とか
みんな来て 高級ホテルなんかに泊まっちゃって
すごいお金使って そこで時間むちゃむちゃなんとかなんとかあんたこうやって
何一つもしゃべってもないし
何も結果が出てこないし
もう何も意見は述べないし
結局来る連中も何も意見述べるぐらいのものでもないんです
ただ名前を売れ売れてるだけなんです
だから名前を売るのは大体偽物だからね
本物は別に自分の名前を売りたくないんですね
ですから 有名であっても結構肩書きはいっぱいあって
まあやっぱり内容はなくなってないんです
結局 それでもうしゃべるだけであって
時間なくなる 何も結果が出てこない
それだったら何のために世界国際会議やるんですかと
で そんな大きいスケールではなくたって
私たちもね いつでも会社でも
やっぱり家族の中でも家族会議やったりとか
会社でいろんな会議やったりとか考えたりするんだけど
結局助からない意見は出てこないんです
そこら辺も気をつけてほしいんです
例えば会社の場合は部下は何か知ってるかもしれません
でも上司はもう先に喋って
こういうこういうことで
彼がこういうことですとか一旦言っちゃったら
じゃあ君らはどうですかね
この問題についてとか聞いたっても
部下は知ってるんだけど
なんか言いづらくて言いづらくて
そういうこともあるし
ということは 結局そういう会議は単なる時間の無駄であって
何の意味もなくなってしまっちゃうんです
それで じゃあみんな自由に意見を言いなさいと言ったら
みんな散々あっちから一つ
こっちから一つの意見もいろんな意見が出てきて
じゃあどうすればいいんですか？それだったら
まとめられなくなっちゃうし
ややこしい世界ですよ
結局 まあ要は我々会社にしろ
家族の運営にしろ 社会のことにしろ
やっぱりその現象がいかに現れたかんで現れたかという原因はしっかり知ってないということ
だから問題です だから困っているんだと
そんなものですね まあ少々頭にちょっと休みをあげながら
ちょっとポイントを次に変えます
ポイントを変える時は考えなくていいんです
で また戻るんです ちょっと話を
じゃあ原因は知ってますかということで
原因は知られますか？ということで
僕は時計を例を出したんですね
で 私の手からこの時計落ちたならば
皆様はもう喧嘩しない
みんな一斉にこれは落っこっちゃったんだから壊れたんですよと
決めちゃうでしょ？もし決めたならば
皆様を責めてるわけじゃないんだけど
もしそういう風に過程として決めたならば
私にはいろいろ意見がいるんです
違う意見 じゃあ起こる
これ落ちる前にこの時計は壊れていなかったんですかね？それ確かめてないでしょ
結局 で こうやって皆様に見えるようにポーンと落っこっちゃったらもう壊れた
それで落っこっちゃったんだから壊れたんだとすぐ決めますけど
じゃあその前 これは正しく動いていた時計でしたかね
もしかすると前からもこれガラスは割れていろいろあった可能性あるでしょ
だから目で見てもそんなもんなんです
因縁っていうのは それ一つだけポイント
それで じゃあ落ちたんだから壊れたというわけが正しいんですかね？それ正しくないんです
落ちたんだから時計壊れたということであるならば
時計というのは落ちるたびに壊れるはずなんですね
でも落ちただけでは壊れるわけじゃないんです
絨毯の上に落ちだったら何のこともないんだから
ですから それもちょっとおかしいし
あるいは落ちたんだから壊れたんじゃなくて
これは壊れるような脆いものであったならば
壊れた原因はこの時計の中にあるんだよとも言えるんじゃないんですか
これしっかり作っていてならばね
ちょっとだけのショックでは壊れるはずがないんだから
ですから 時計が壊れた原因は時計にありますよと
あるいは落ちたことにありますよと
あるいは落ちた地面 受けた地面の床の状態にありますよと
何でも言えるんです ということは
皆様の目の前でこの時計を落っことしても
なぜ時計が壊れたんですか？という質問に正確に答えられないということなんです
そんな具体的な例にしたって
だから因縁論は難しいんです
因縁論で扱うのはそんなポイントじゃないんです
なぜ人間は生命がどうやって現れているんですかと
なぜ生命は苦しんでいるんですか？なぜ我々の心の中であれこれ煩悩が生まれているんですかと
なぜ人間に輪廻転生というものがあるんですかと
どうすれば輪廻転生を乗り越えるんですかと
なぜ人間には悟りという境地は開かませんですかと
もし開こうとするならば
どうすればいいんですか？というすごい簡単な問題なんです
因果論で扱っているのは
という時計なぜ落ちたんですか？という答えなんです
ですから  やっぱり勉強するべきか逃げるべきかというのは
皆様方が決めなくちゃいけないんです
で 一応難しいということだけね
分かったらいいんじゃないですか
なんで私はそんなに楽天的だという的だというと
この実践方法ですか このだいたいまあ我々仏教で言っているこの簡単な実践方法を正直な心でやってみると
この知識ではなくて 頭ではなくて
何かどこかでやっぱり全部わかってきますよ
言葉で喋れないだけなんですね
例えば時計は落っこっちゃあれば一応知ってるんでしょうね
床が硬くあって ある程度高いところから落ちたし
この時計もそれなりに弱いものであったし
まあそういういろいろものがあって壊れたんだと
ですから 時計にも原因があって
床にも原因があって 落ちた速さにも原因があって
落ちた角度やら高さやら
そういうものにも原因があって
結局地球にも原因があって
これはもう地球のせいだからね
そういういろんなものがあって
時計は壊れたんだと こんなことはもう言葉でない場合は知ってるでしょうに
言葉で喋ろうと思ったら喋れないだけ
言葉で何か言ったら私はすぐ反対意見出せるんだから
これは自分を料理しているとね
まあどうやって 何て言うの
調味料ですか このお塩やらお醤油やらいろいろ味をつけるでしょ
これちゃんと何ミリグラムとかね
何ミリリットルとか計算して入れるんですかね
砂糖は0点3ミリグラムと
お塩は2.5グラムとか
お醤油はこれぐらいミリリットルとかね
ちゃんと実験室のようにいい感じで
ちゃんと正確に量って入れたりとか
そんなことやらないでしょう
でもどこかで知ってるんですよ
これぐらい入れたいばいいんだと
古い人々だったらね どうかし現代人だったら
まあもうまた舐めてみて
また舐めてみて またまだまだとかね
別に上手な人は全然味見をしない
ただ入れた入れた もう作った
終わりと これで終わりと
それぐらいできるんです
僕ら小さい時はよく見ていたんですね
僕らは普通にご飯が普通の釜で炊くんだから
これ結構難しくて で 初めて炊く人
ご飯炊く場合は一生懸命心配で心配で蓋を開けてみるは
またちょっと取って冷ましてみる
いろいろなことをやってるんです
それでもう苦労して汗を流しながら一応ご飯炊いて終わったって
結局上手に炊けてないんですよ
それでできる人は何のこともなく
米を洗って水をサーッと入れて
もう釜に入れて火にかけて火をつけて
それで終わり どこか行って何かやってきて
また時間抜けたらあれ開けて
で 開けたりなんとかして
それでぴったし出来上がっちゃう
だからああいう風に このなんとなくこの知識でない世界で真理を知られるようになるんです
ですから この因果論の難しい世界も
あの まあ修行さえすれば
まあ実践さえすれば まあどこかでなんとなくわかってきますので
で 私はもうあまりこの知識的な攻撃については
まあそれほどまあ気にしないというか
楽観的でよかったということなんです
いわゆる頭ではわかることはね
なんかどこかでもう引っかかってしまっちゃうということなんです
じゃあいろいろ因果法則あるんだけど
お釈迦様はだいたいたくさんお経の中でいろんなところで因果論の喋っている
そんなを喋っている時は
このなぜ苦しみが生まれるんですかと
それだけは明確に説明しているんです
なぜ苦しみが生まれるんですかと
それを探求しましょうと
それはいいんだけど 問題はもっと先に行っちゃうんです
で 問題は我々は本当に生命というのは苦しみかと思ってるんですかね
生きていることは苦しみだと
大変だと思ってるんですかね
ですから ポイントはこの生きていることは苦しいんだ
大変だと分かった人にとっては
なぜこの苦しみが生まれるかという
問題が現れるんであって
まあ生きててよかったと幸福で幸福でたまらないと思ってるならば
もうそんな問題はどうでもいいじゃないかなんと
で よく何回僕にも聞いたんだけど
だからみんな例えば男性だったらすごい苦労して一生懸命仕事をすると
それで仕事終わったら酒いっぱい飲むと
この仕事終わったこの酒はもうあまりにもおいしくてもう一生懸命頑張れるんだと
ですから 一生懸命仕事を一筋で苦労しながら
どんな苦労でも耐えて頑張ってやってるのは
終わったら酒いっぱい飲むためなんですね
で この間熱海に行く時でも
電車隣の席に座ってた一応三十
四十一 二代ぐらいの男性かな
まあ結構格好つけて座っていたんだけど
まあで 私は見たら同性
まあ違う人間だから話しかけたんで
それでお互いに話してて
もういきなりまあ宗教を攻撃して
自分たちがこういう まあいわゆるこの無神教という人々ですよと
で で 私 まあ私はそういう話を聞いて
なんか自分たちのことを宗教ばっかり信じていて
我々は情けないと思う
思うかもしれません 向こうは思ったでしょうね
自分たちが現代人で知識人で無神教ですよと
私の口には世の中の猿
猿 犬とかいくらでもいますよ
いくらでもいますよと
壊れなかったみたい で言えたんだけど
それを言わないで まあそういう
まあそういう方々は結構いますよと言って
向こうも話したんですね
それで彼が言うのは まあやっぱり自分たちが仕事をして
そういう生き方で結構だと思ってるんだと
これ仕事終わったらこの酒飲むとこの酒はおいしいんだと
いて すごく自分が人生は幸福で満ち満ちあふれていると思っていてしゃべるんですね
で 私は見たら まあその二
三百円で買える缶のビール飲んでるだけのことなんですね
小田原で だからもうまあ町田で降りたんだけど
それで自分が最高に幸福だと
だから別にあの人幸福じゃないというわけじゃないんです
その人はそう思ってるし
で だからどっち考える？ただのこのね
缶ビール 1つ買って 電車でこうやって飲むってこと
最高に幸福ですかねとかね
それぐらいですかとかね
幸福っていうのは それに一生苦労して仕事をするんですか？とかね
彼が一応いろいろ象徴的なことも言いたかったんだけど
まあ酒で彼にとっては何を象徴しているかとは
まあちょっとまあちょっと
でも言葉でない世界で彼が言ってることもわかります
彼が一応言ってるのは
この一生懸命苦労して仕事をして
最後に仕事終わったなとほっとする瞬間は気持ちいいんです
でも 彼の知識 能力ではそういうふうに言えないだけなんです
私たちよりすごく頭のいい知識人たちだから
自分が結局言ってるのは
このそれは誰にでもあるしね
なんか大変な仕事か何かあって
それをもう一生懸命もう歯を噛んでやって終わっちゃう
やって終わった瞬間はすごく楽しいんです
あれなんですね ですから
彼がそれをもう最後の酒一杯はもうかなり美味しいんだと生まれていて
缶ビールを飲んでると
ですから 問題は缶ビールかあるいはウイスキー飲んでるかということではないんです
あるいは酒飲んでないかということではなくて
まあきつい仕事  1日のきつい仕事終わったんだという
このフィナーレのお祭りなんですね
で まあそういうふうなケースを言ったのは
ただこのフィナーレのお祭りだけ
打ち上げだけだけ見て一生苦労するならば
それで人生は幸福だと思っているならば
このなぜ苦しみが生まれるかという原因は説明してもしなくてもどうでもいいんです
その人々はもうどうしようもないというかね
でもうちょっと原因結果知ればどうですかと
ただそれぐらいばかりでいいんですかと
目に見えるもの 耳に聞こえるもの
身の回りのものだけで
私はもうこんなもんだ
こんなもんだと 私はもう目を回ったら宇宙は見えないんだから宇宙はありませんと
外を見たところでアメリカは見えなかったんだから
アメリカなんかありっこはないんですかと
そんな話ですから 言ってるの
結局ですから ただそれだけでいいんですかと
もっと客観的に見ると
やっぱり 1 日仕事をして
8時間  10時間とかすごく苦しくて
そこで酒飲んで 1時間楽しがっていると
だから 1時間の楽しみに10時間の苦しみだから
10対 1 なんですね じゃあそれ変えたらどうですかね
10時間酒飲んで遊んで
1時間仕事をすると 変えても同じことなんです
別にそういう人いますよ
ちょっと 1時間仕事をすれば
まあ 1週間食べるものは儲かるんだと
それだったら 1時間仕事して10時間酒飲めるでしょうに
じゃあその人はこの 10時間仕事をする人と違って 10時間楽しんでるんですけど
違うんです 10時間酒飲むっていうことは
これ大変な苦しみなんです
そうすると 1時間仕事をすること楽しみになっちゃうんです
そういうふうなことで
だから我々の人生というのはいかに何ですかと
幸福ですか 不幸ですかと
そこら辺も考えてからなんですよ
この因果説に行くのは
例えばもう一応計算すれば
人生はね まあお金もありましたし
問題はなかったし 自分好きな人と結婚もできたし
まあ子供も大きくなりましたし
別にもう引いて言えば何も問題なかったんだと思ったら
やっぱり自分が恵まれてるんだと
神様の御寵によってもう大変ありがたく感じさせて生きてるんだとかね
まあそれぐらいの考え方だったら
まあそれ以上なかなか何も進めなくなっちゃうし
人間の心は それに止まってしまっちゃうし
それ哲学ではないんですね
そういうことは たまに言うんです
自分が神を信じてるんだと
なぜですかと言ったら
自分がすごく幸福ですよと
だからあんたおかしいんだと
神を信じないのはと 言われる場合あるんです
そう言われたらすごく私は怒るんです
なぜならば あなたは幸福だから神が信じちゃって
私は不幸だから じゃあ不幸な連中はどうすればいいんですかね
ですから そういう哲学的なお話にならないんです
たまたまその人は幸福だと感じただけ
缶ビール 1本飲みながら
えらいもう世界一流の幸福を感じた人は
あの時も私に話しましたから
どうせ感じてるだけのことだから
だからそこで止まらないで
さらに進める人々に因果論なんです
一般の人々にはもうやっぱり近寄り難いんです
その世界は 宇宙の本当の秘密っていうのは
いい例が出ますよ 例えば我々は水の中にいる魚なんですよと
そこでもう餌だったら何でもいいんじゃと
いいんじゃんと思って泳いでると
もう誰かが あの なんて言いますか
で もうあれなんて言いますか
もう釣り竿でね 餌を出してるんで
あんな簡単に取れる餌があるんだから
私は食べますよと 食っちゃいますよと行って
それをパクッと食べちゃうと
食べて食べちゃったら
当然その魚は釣られますけど
そんなもんなんですね
人間の人生っていうのは
それでポイントは あの魚が勉強しますかね
自分のバカバカらしさに
釣られた魚が 勉強しないでしょ
もう取られたんだから
釣られたんだから もう今や魚になって塩焼きになってるんだから
もう本人に知る余地もなくなっちゃうんです
ですから 魚の生き方も大変だと
簡単な餌は取るなと 餌だったら自分で頑張ってあっちこっち行って苦労して探して食べなさいという正しい道が
あの魚に教えられませんよ
まあ魚も人間みたいな家族でいたならば
もう両親 親父がお母さんの魚が子供たちに
あなた方はね もうこんなにも楽をしようとするなと思うなと
餌場合はもういつでも餌きちんと口の先に食べなさい
食べなさいと 恵まれてる場合は気をつけろと
というふうに教えたっても
やっぱり一人の魚が いえ
私は恵まれてるんだと
神様は私のことを大変親切に守ってるんだと
ですから神様はどうぞ召し上がってください
私の口先に餌を持ってくるんだから
私は食べますよと言ったら
これはもうどうしようもないんです
お母さんがあんたそれ食べちゃったらひどい目に遭いますよ
言ったって もうもう食べたらそれで終わっちゃいますからね
勉強することができなくなっちゃうんです
ですから 人間の中でも大体もうそういう
まあこれでいいやと もう幸福でね
平和でと思ったら 真理を知ることはできなくなっちゃうんです
ですから この人生を観察して
本当に人生は苦しみがないかと
本当に幸福がないかと分かったところで原因を探したくなるんです
で ずっと私は言ってますけど
やっぱりこの存在っていうのは苦しみというものから
表現しているんです 唯一の宇宙の OS システムはドッカなんです
これはどんな生命にも共通していて
すごい便利なんです 我々が作っているコンピューターと違うんです
いろいろ OS システムありますから困ってるんだけど
宇宙はたった一つの OS で動いているんです
OS ってのはご存知ですね
もうなんとなく知ってる方に聞いてください
説明ちょっと難しいんだけど
で ある基本的なプログラムがありまして
決まりがありまして 掟がありまして
掟という言葉は誰でもわかりますから
宇宙に一つの掟があります
それはドッカということなんです
それは仏教の真理の第 1 として教えているんです
それは日本語で苦だと
苦しみだとね 簡単に漢字を入れちゃって
まあ意味がわからなくなっちゃって苦労していますけど
これ大変な意味のある言葉なんです
でもまあドッカっていうのは苦しみだと理解したっても構いません
なんか納得いかない 不満
苦しみ 虚しい 安定しないという状態はドッカなんですね
納得いかない 不満 苦しい
安定しない 虚しい 全部その意味が入っているんです
ただ虚しい そういうふうにドッカと言った途端
仏教ではもう一つ攻撃しているんです
宇宙には何か意味があるんだと
この存在には何か意味があるんだと
我々がここにいるのは何か意味があるんだぞと
生命はこの一生懸命頑張って生きているのは
何かやっぱり目的があってそうなるんだと目的を考えたりはするんですね
やっぱり何か訳があるんだ
何か訳との過去の訳ではなくて
これから何かそれなりのことがあって
我々は生きているんだと
それを仏教ではちょっとケチをつけてるんです
なんか訳があって生きているんではなくて
ただ虚しいと ただ生きているんだということを
で それ生きているんだと言ったって自分だけなんですけど
このドッカっていうのは
この自分の体から見ればわかるんです
この体っていうのは細胞一つで出来上がっちゃうし
この細胞一つが生まれた時から
もうこの細胞はもうすぐ死ぬんでしょうに
細胞ってのは大体 80年ぐらい持てますかね
80 年間は持てないでしょうね
1ヶ月間も経たないうちにそれ壊れちゃうんですね
じゃあ 1ヶ月間の立てない 1週間で死にたいという人がいるんですかね
生まれて やっぱりこの食われてしまうことについては
その細胞もやっぱり不安なんです
細胞一向にしたっても
嫌なんです それは すぐ消えて
もう現れたばっかりで
細胞としてもう消えなくちゃいけないんだから
何のためにその細胞現れたんですかね
その場合は 何のためでもないんです
ただ消えるためなんですね
それでその細胞は頑張るんです
自分がこのあの DNA でいれば壊れちゃうでしょ
それ自分が勝手に何て言いますか
分けて新しい外から新しい物質を入れてもらっちゃう
言って DNA の 2つ作ってしまっちゃうんですね
遺伝の それでこのシステムと自分をごまかしちゃうんです
まだまだ若いばっかしだよと
いわゆる外から頂いたアミノ酸にも依存しているんだから
この日光の細胞がちょっと前の細胞が分かっちゃってます
ちょっと勢い乗りちゃうんです
それでどんどん細胞分裂して大きくして
もういろいろ臓器が出てきて
我々人間としているんだけど
その働きはずっと同じく続けているんです
すぐ壊れる すぐ死ぬ 今も死んでるんで
いつでもいつでも それでごまかしちゃう
いい まだまだ若いんだと
頭ではそう思ってるでしょ
まだまだ若いんだと もう死ぬのは早いんだと
それをもう細胞一個一個から来るメッセージなんです
それでご飯何で食べてるんですかというと
やっぱり食べて この古いものは取り出して
新しいものちょっとパッチをかけてね
なんとか壊れるとか ちょっとパッチパッチパッチして
何とか何とかと 一個の細胞で不安だから
日光横行なったりしてね
もう何億 何兆 何万個にも細胞になって塊になって頑張ってるんですね
いわゆる集合体としてね
そこでこの なんで私たちはこんなに一生懸命生きてますかというと
あの不安なんです ああ
嫌だと すぐ壊れるんだと
すぐ死ぬんだと というそれなんです
だから頑張るんです 死ぬんだから頑張るんです
死ぬんだからご飯食べる
死ぬんだから仕事をする
死ぬんだから もう外に寝たら死ぬんだから
建物なんか作る もし死にませんよと誰かに言われたら
あれではもう もし死なない状態になったならば
それで人間それっきり何人も死ないようになっちゃう
でも頭の中では死なない状態いいなと思う
それも分かりますよ ずっと死の恐怖感に追われてるんだから
頑張ってるんだから 限りなく努力して死なないために
ですから 死なない状態っていうのはすごく面白い目的として思ってるんです
ですから この不死なる境地っていうのは
いろんな宗教出てきますけど
そういう風に現れてくるたわごとであってと
そんな境地はあるんじゃないんだと
というのがお釈迦様の考え方なんです
で それぐらいの苦しみのシステム
それからもうちょっと考えましょう
で ご飯食べなかったら体苦しい
ご飯食べたら体が苦しい
仕事をしたら体が苦しい
それで休んだら 寝たらもう終わってる
また体の調子が良くないと
で どうしますっても 体は苦しむということで動いているんですよ
我々呼吸を吸っていることも
心臓鼓動していることも
全部このペイン苦しみなんですね
それがなければ もう人間は本当にもう危ないことをするんです
ですから体が壊れるんだ
死ぬんだとわかっても
麻薬のことを知っている人はもうやめられないんですね
麻薬使ったら自分の体は壊れて死んじゃうよとわかってるんだけど
一回使ったらもう二度と三度と使う
なぜですかね やっぱりその時はなんか楽しいでしょうね
普通の人間だったら ご飯食べたらそんなに楽しいわけじゃないし
断食したっても楽しいわけじゃないし
やっぱり苦しみがそこにあるんです
そこで麻薬なんか使う人々は一時的
瞬間的かもしれませんだけど
この苦しみの体を守ろうということをちょっと置いておいて
なんか変な世界に入って楽しみを味わっちゃう
それだったら体は死んでもいいやと思って
それをもう使ってしまっちゃうんです
ということは 体は生命は苦しみの下で出来上がっているということなんです
で 例えば心臓発作を起こしたらすごく快感が生まれるならば
人間は心臓発作を起こしたすぐ死んじゃうんで
病院に行かないんです
でも心臓発作なんか起こしたらすごい
もう一番痛いんだそうです
他の病気よりは 気が狂うほど痛いんだそうで
ですから すぐもう治療を受けちゃう
例えば 体の中にがんが現れたんだと
どんどんがんが成長すると
気持ちよくて気持ちよくて
もうすごい気持ちいいんだと思うならどうなるんですか
がんに侵されて早く死んじゃうでしょ
例えば子供がどんどんご飯食べて大きくなってくると
大人にとってはすごい気持ちいいし
そんな感じで自分の体にがんが出てきて
それがどんどんどんどん大きくなっていくんだ
それを楽しく楽しくしょうがないというならば
もうガンは早く出てきたらもう年以内でもう死んじゃうんだから
何か治療しないと 人間死ぬでしょうに
ですから 苦しみは命を守るために生きていきたいために出来上がっているプログラムなんですね
それは生命のOSシステムだと私は言いたいんです
全ての生命はその OS でプログラムされていて
犬猫は苦しみの中 苦しみという基本的な掟で生きてるんです
敵から逃げるのは 敵に捕われて苦しいんだから
猫でも餌 獲物なんか取る時は自分の体はちゃんと守って獲物を狙っちゃいますね
ということはちゃんと苦しみということを知ってるんです
だから猫であるか人間であるかっていうのは我々個人のプログラムであって
基本的な全て生命にOSがドッカであります
それを分かった人には
なぜこのドッカで存在はプログラムしているんですか？ということはわかる
やっぱりわかるんじゃなくて気になるんです
全ての生命は神様に創られたんだと思ったら
因果法則は関係ないんです
勉強しなくてもいいんです
我々は神様の大恩寵によって創られているんだと思うならば
まあ因果法則の話は関係ない
もし生命は苦しみに基づいて全ては出来上がってるなと思ったら
なんでそうなってるんでしょうかと聞きたくなるし
それで因果法則を説明しなくちゃいけないし
どういうことかというと
全ての生命は苦しみによって出来上がっているということは客観的事実なんです
1 秒1秒楽しくて楽しくて
ワクワクして もう何て言いますか
エンドルフィンばっかり脳細胞から出してる人全然いませんだから我々一日中アドレナリンばっかり出しても緊張ばっかりですから
ですから苦しいんですよ
とにかく それは客観的事実を認めたところで
それは神様が創ったというのは
ちょっとなんか都合が悪いんですね
神様が創ったならば まあいくらなんでも我々よりはちょっとでも頭の方がいいんだから
いいものを作るはずなんですね
なぜならば 人間が創ってる車であろうが
飛行機であろうが それほど悪くないんだから
神様が創った生命はもう少々マシであるはずなんですね
ということだから 別にこの一切は苦であると分かったところで
全ては神に創られたという考え方は
仏教徒にとってはどうでもいい話になっちゃうんです
そんなものは それよりは
なぜこの苦しみが生まれるかと
じゃあ一個だけ仏教の話を聞いて
因果法則の例を出してみましょう
僕はたくさん言おうかなと思ってたんで
言って言ってそれから時間があればです
例えばこういうこと この
認識システムですかね
ちょっと言葉が思い浮かばないんですが
我々は物事を認識しているんですね
その認識しているシステムの中で
いつでもいろいろ苦しみが生まれるんだと
で 分かりやすいんです
例えばこういうこと これもちゃんと分かりやすく仏教に書いてあるんです
目があるんだと それから目に入る対象があるんだと
一応あるでしょう 目があって
目に見えるものがあって
チャックンチャパキッチャルーペーチッと
それで目がそれを見るということをするんですね
目に何か見えるのは見られる何かあるんだから
そこで 3つのことが出来上がっちゃう
我々に目という働きがあって
見られるものという働きがあって
見られるという働きが生まれてくる
見られたんだと チャックインニャーナというものが生まれる
それは視覚ですか 生まれるんだ
それでティンナンサンガティパスソーという言葉があります
その 3つが合わせると
目の働きと見られるものの働きと見たということ
合わせるとちょっとしたエネルギーが生まれるんですね
体に 何か見たらそうでしょ
何か何を見るために何かちょっとエネルギーが生まれるんじゃないの
この３種類のエネルギーぶつかるんだから
もうまた違うエネルギーが生まれてくる
たまに何か見ただけで
すごくものすごいエネルギーが生まれる場合もあるし
まあかすかなエネルギーもある場合もあるし
どうしても目に何か映ったらそこに新しいエネルギーが生まれる
それはこの３つの組み合わせによってパスという即という触れるというエネルギーなんです
言葉で言えば触れる 即
パーリ語ではパス どこですか？触ですかね
あの 今言ってる言葉っていうのは
まあ一応この仏教の魂のように
この存在構想を解釈する
解読する あの鍵の言葉なんです
分かりやすく説明しますけど
これで全部鍵を解いて解くんです
存在の で この３つのエネルギーは一緒になります ３
つのエネルギーっていうのは
目 目に見えるものと目で見ること
それで即という触れた
なんで触れたという字が言うんですか？それすごく簡単分かりやすいんですね
対象に触れたんだと 分かりやすいんだけど
やっぱり何かこの私という働きが外にある世界とぶつかって触れたことなんです
いわゆる宇宙はたった一つかもしれませんだけど
その宇宙の自分という孤立した
ものは宇宙を別々に認識したことなんですね
バカバカらしいことですけど
結局 例えば水の 水の 海の水のように我々は同じ海だと思っていて
その海の海水の一滴が
いえ 自分が別にいるんだと思って
別にこれは海だと認識する
あれ？大きなお世話というか
バカバカしいですよ 一滴の水が大きな水
海のすべての水を別に
これは海だと認識すると
自分がちっちゃな一滴の水になって
あれ巨大な海に対して何にもできなくなっちゃうんだから
そんなこと考えないで
海の水だから海の水でいればいいのにね
個人的な孤立しないで
インディバデュアティオンですか
アイデンティフィケーションしないでいたならばよかったのに
でもどうもこの私も宇宙のそのものなんですけど
自分がいると認識しちゃうんですよ
このホールがあるんだと
皆様がいるんだと この認識しちゃったら
まあこれから大変です
皆様方いるんだから 私は皆様方のことを気にしなくちゃいけないし
皆様方に大変礼儀正しく振る舞わなくちゃいけないし
所詮私は生まれつき礼儀が悪いんだけど
それ私にとってすごいきついんですね
喋る時は考えて考えて喋らなくちゃいけないし
私は自分の国の言葉で喋った方が一番楽なのに
でも皆様方いるんだからと思っているんだから
私は国の言葉で喋らないんですね
それで苦労しているんです
挨拶しなくちゃいけないとかいろいろ出てきますから
それはどこから出てくる？自分がいるという存在から出てくるんですね
いわゆるこの即という働きだからすごい大事なんですよ
この結局何のことなく宇宙のエネルギーが自分の同じ宇宙のエネルギーに触れたところで
即という波が作っちゃうんです
パス  contact で
これ英語では contact
なんで contact を言うんですか？これ誰と contact するんですか？宇宙は宇宙と contact するんでしょう
そこで宇宙は何か自分が個人だと
個が あれ 自我他にコンタクトする
そこで初めて自と他の区別が生まれてくるんですね
どうでもいいことを 例えば光あるでしょ
この部屋の中で 光はこのお尻も触れるし
背中にも触れるし 頭にも触れる
どこで触れるんでしょうね
別にここら辺はいくら光があったって
僕はこの辺見てて こっちにこの辺見て
こっちに光が当たって
全然どうでもいいんです
その場合は でも 目に入ったところでどうなるんですか？目に入った瞬間で
私は世界と宇宙と私は区別するんです
あ 私はこっちいて こっちは光があるんだと
これはお寺だと たったそれだけのことです
いっぱい背中にも光が当たっているのに
全然もう自と他も何もないんです
これ目に光が触れただけで
あ あるんじゃないかと
外の世界 自分と違う世界
それでまあ全部自分の
これ全部目に光が映ったんだからなんです
日本はあるわ 国はあるわ
外国はあるわとかね 宇宙があるわ
いろんな星が星々があるんだとかね
まあ考えること考えること
全てはこの目に光が触れただけで
この私が存在しているんだと
えらい勘違いするんです
それものすごい勘違いなんです
で この水で言うならば
例えば水がこういう風にあるんだ
それは水 それで一つの水
波がこうなって またこちらの波がこうなってきて
ああ こんにちは はじめまして
言ったってどうってことないでしょう
結局水だから お前 はじめましてつったって同じ水でしょう
で この波のように まあちょっと相手と出会うんです
もう自分なんです 結局
自分っていうのおかしいんだけども
別にどうってことない宇宙の流れですけど
ですから 即というこの目があって
眼という働きがあって
光という働きがあって
いわゆる見られるものという働きがあって
それで見られるという働きが生まれる
見るという働きが生まれる
その 3つの組み合わせは即と言うんです
なぜ即と言うんですかというと
自と他の即 そこで初めて生まれる主体と客体の区別
そこで初めて生まれる
ああ 難しいことを私も言っちゃいなってきます
この即からアッサパッチャーヴェーダ
即からチューが生まれる
感受性というものが生まれる
目に何か映ったらそこで触れちゃって
それからこの感じるんですね
見えた見えたと 感じたものに対して我々は
まあいろいろものは感じる
とにかく 感じたところで
次にこのタンハー 渇愛が生まれてくる
タンハーっていうのは渇愛と訳しますからね
なんか渇ですから この渇いてるんだから
そこからもうなんかもうおかしいんだと
満たされないんだと という問題はそこから生まれるんです
大体まあそこからは話は簡単ですけど
で もし我々はもう存在の元々の同じエネルギーでいかなければ
私ということではなくて
ただのエネルギーですからね
宇宙のエネルギーですから
まあどうでもいいことですから
そこでその中のもうかすかとも言えないほどの一部が外の宇宙を認識しちゃうっていうのは
しちゃうでしょ あるんだと
そこにはパッサというんですね
即と で 自分が認識したならば
認識ということを感じちゃうんだから
上が生まれる 感受性が生まれる
そこで自分でしょ 認識したのは
もう宇宙から離れてるでしょ
宇宙は巨大であって 宇宙には勝てっこはないんだから
自分はというのはもう一時的な存在だから
ただの幻覚だから 大きなもう大大海のたったのかすかな波一つですから
それはまあすぐ抑えちゃいますから
どうでもいいんです それは
その波 ちょっとした波が
その一滴 その一滴のちょっとした水のちょっとした粒が自分を守ろうとしちゃうんですね
見ているんだから もっと見たいんだと
聞いてるんだから もっと聞きたいんだと
宇宙のことは 今考えてるんだから
世の中のこと 宇宙のことをもっと考えたいんだと思っちゃうでしょう
皆さんはそう思ってるかもしれません
宇宙のことを知りたい
過去のことを知りたい
未来のことを知りたい
人が死んじゃったらどうなるか知りたいと
まあバカ言うなと 初めからバカなことをしてっていうことは答えなんです
大きな湖で一滴の水があ
自分がいて もう水 海があるんだと
海があるんだと それでその一滴の水が
やっぱりうち海のことは全部知りたいなと思っちゃう
それでその水一滴が本当に知られるんですかね
で 自分がもう消えちゃうでしょ
どうせ海に消えちゃったらもう見られないでしょ
海を それで不満が生まれてくるんです
ああ 死にたくないんだと
一滴の別な水でずっといて
海を観察したいんだと思い
存分 そういうふうに我々も自分を作っちゃって
宇宙を知りたい 世界を知りたいとか
因果法則を知りたいとか
と苦しんでるんです その苦しみはどこから生まれたんですかというと
この認識なんですね 最初から
なぜ主体客体と分けて認識したんですかと
そこら辺なんです 問題は
なぜ我々は外の世界 別々に認識するんですかと
認識するたびにそこが生まれてきて
それによって感受性が生まれてきて
それからやっぱりありとあらゆる不満やら死にたくないやら
いろんな渇愛が生まれてくる
渇愛と同時に やっぱり生きていきたいという執着がウパーダナが生まれる
執固守 頑固と取ること
もう自分を守らないと死んじゃうでしょう
渇愛が生まれたんだから
自分を守らなくちゃ だからあれ
これ食べたら長生きできますよと
この運動すれば体が元気になります
働きは全部そういうところから出てくるって全部
あの山に入って修行してたらすごい精霊
精神的な力がつきますよと
インドに行って瞑想すれば
いろんな仙人たちの力が注いできて
もう大変気持ちいいんですよと
アメリカのなんとか人がいて
このチャネリングしていろんなエネルギーを入れてくれますよとか
言うは言うは言うは まあ世の中のいろんなこと
それで私は全部全く聞いても聞いてないふりをして
結局ほとんどバカにしているんだから
私ほどバカがいないと
またかえって私に攻撃までするんだ
するわ それをまた見て
私はまた楽しくて 楽しくて
楽しくて 何やってるんですかと
そういうふうな教えは仏教の教えなんですね
残念ですけど それは因果法則なんで
とにかく ウパーダナ執着が生まれた
ウパーダナパッチャ バオ
まあまた自分としての存在は続くんですね
バオっていうのは存在
有なんですね いわゆるもうビー
英語で言えばビーアイエイチのビー
ザイン ドイツ語で言えばいるということ
もうなんとかしなくちゃと
まあ執着が生まれてくるで
とにかく執着が生まれてきたら
それからまあ頑張る 一滴の水が自分一滴の水でいるため
いわゆる個 個を作って個人ですか
個はこういうふうに書くんですか
で こう 個を作ったんだから個を守らなくちゃいけないんですね
それでやってる全ての働きは有と言うんです
個を守るために で 服は服着るは
食事作るはご飯食べるは
仕事をするは 宗教にも行くは
瞑想をするは もう何だかんだ人間やってることは
この個を守るためなんです
徳を積むはまた罪を犯すは
会社のお金を誤魔化すは
銀行のお金を誤魔化すは
いろんなことをしたり
もう何しようが山に籠もって修行しようが
銀行強盗やろうが それ全部個を守るためにやるもんで
それは有と言うんですね
あるいはカルマのエネルギーもそれなんですね
だからエネルギー いろいろなことやるんだから
もう何とかの形で続くんです
でも残念ながら このある一滴の水が自分を守ろうと頑張っても
その一滴の水がずっとあるわけじゃないんです
すぐ消えちゃいますから
でも一滴の水が有は個という存在は作るんでしょ？いっぱいのエネルギーが
作っちゃうんだから 当然その一滴の水が消えちゃいますよ
違う一滴が出てきてしまう
それはこういうことなんです
だから波といううちが見えるんですよ
水がこういう風に まあ例えば
水がこういうふうにあるだ
こういうふうにあった水がある日突然このちっちゃな波を作ったならば
目に見えないほど あまり大きく描いてはいけないんです
この目にまあ この辺に描きます
例えばこうやってあるべき水は
ここでちょっとした波を作ったならば
どうなるんですかね その波が永遠にここにいるんですか？いない
その代わりこの波は消える
消えるんだけど 自分作ったエネルギーのせいで
こちらにその波が移っちゃうんです
だからこっちで波が当然上がった波が下がっちゃいますから
下がると違うところで違う波が生まれてくる
それで場は有は新しい存在は作ってしまっちゃうんです
波と同じなんです 一つの波が生まれてきて
ああ 自分が別に波でいて
海が別にいるんだと思ったところで
だから私はずっとこのままいたいんだと思ったその波がすぐ消えてしまうんです
威張ったって 消えた瞬間にもまた違う波が生まれてくる
その違う波はまた やっぱり私がいて
海が別とにいるんだと
私は全ての意味を知り尽くしたいんだと思う
思う前にその波はまた消えてしまっちゃう
で その代わりにまた違う波が生まれる
その違う波が まあやっぱり海があって
私が別にいて これを何とかして知りたいなと思う
もうそのとっくに前にその波はまた消えてしまっちゃう
そういう風に輪廻の中で生命がもうそことそこの世界知りたいなと思う前に死んじゃうんです
皆様もどうでしょうかね
小さい時から勉強しなくちゃいけないし
ああしなくちゃいけない
そんなことをやってると
やっとちょっと暇が取ると
仏教を勉強したり 宇宙のことを勉強する暇がないでしょうに
もう先が だから知らないうちにもう死んでしまっちゃうんです
それでもう新しい波がまた生まれちゃう
それは全く自分が生まれ変わるということでもなく
全く違う生命が生まれ変わるということでもなく
全く無意味なんです ただ波を起こすだけなんです
例えば私というスマナサーラという個が死んで他のところで生まれるならば
それは面白い話でしょう
皆様には面白くないかもしれませんだけど
私にとっては面白いんだけど
またスマナサーラが生まれ変わったらこうあるんだと
でも本人にとってはそれ面白いし
それだったらいっぱいいろいろ徳でも積んで
次にはもっと頑張りますと思っちゃいますけど
でも私の波が消えると違う波が生まれるんですが
そこにまた自分だとも自分でないんだとも
もうどうでもいいことで
ただの波だけ ですから
私に過去があったんだけど
全然知らない 全然知らないし
結局それに関係なく現在だけのことで生きてるんです
海の波が出たらその波が波として
特別な波としているだけで
それで消えてしまっちゃう
消えて違う波が生まれるだけ
そこでババからジャーティが出てくるんだ
ジャーティっていうのは生まれること
この頑張っちゃいますから
このここで個が屋を作りますから
いろんなことをやるんだから
新しい輪廻ですか 新しいものが生まれていく
新しい波が生まれたら
新しい生命として生まれ変わったら
また ジャーティパッチャ ジャラー マラナン ソーカ パリデーワ ドゥッカ ドゥーマナ スーパヤーサ サンバヴァン
すべての苦しみが生まれるんだと
ジャーティからはジャラーマラナン
生まれた時からまあ年取るは病気になるはもう仕事をしなくちゃいけないし
借金もするもありとあらゆる苦しみが出てきて
憂いや悲しみやら エーワ メー タッサ ケワラッサ ドゥッカッカンダス サムドヨ
これはすべての苦しみは像のように現れますよと一応因果説で教えちゃうんですね
だからこれはもう宇宙のシステムであって
生命の基本的な働きを教えるものであって
理解するものは最初から抜群の能力があって
もう人生はとことん観察している人でなければもう意味がないかもしれません
一回ではわからないんです
とにかく ですからそれはわかりますけど
私も これぐらい理解するためにも
それは頭に入れて もう何年間も頭でもういろいろいろいろ理解しようと頑張らないと
とにかくお分かりでしょう
一応このもうどうったことない
このもう現れて消えたりする
この存在の中で ただ単に私たちは自分だという主体客体の区別を作っちゃう
ただそれだけのことで目に何かを映っただけでしょう
始めたのは 目があって目に何か映るんだと
ただそれだけでも全ての輪廻を転生してしまっちゃうんです
目で見ただけ 主体客体も分別して
バイフォケーションという
いわゆる 2つに分けて
それから自分がいるんだと思っちゃったら
自分を守らなくちゃいけない
で 頑張るんだけど 消えてしまっちゃう
頑張ったんだから そのエネルギーで新しい何か存在が現れちゃう
こちらで頑張ったんだから
違う存在が現れる それにも輪廻というんです
だから結局はエネルギーのカラクリだけ
同じく耳もそうなんです
耳があると私がいて 聞こえる音が外にあると我々は区別するんです
鼻があると同じことなの
鼻があって味わえる香りが外の世界にあるんだと
口があるんだから食べる
味わえる味が外にあるんだと思っちゃうし
体があるんだから触れるものは外にあるんだと思っちゃうし
そこでそういうものは探す
私は人間でいるんだからこそ
建物が必要になっちゃうし
家具が必要になっちゃうし
美味しい食べ物は必要になっちゃうし
綺麗な服を必要になっちゃうし
美しい音 音楽を必要になっちゃうし
目に入るものは必要で
全部必要になっちゃって
まあ追っかけていく それは私がいると思ってるんだから
それいくら追っかけてきたっても満足は得られないし
徒競で死んじゃうし  これはこの因果法則のちょっとしたほんの微かなあるお経の解釈です
まだいっぱいあるんです
まあ二度と因果因果説の話を聞けませんと思った
それぐらいいいんですけど
いかがですか そこら辺でやめましょうか